sont les petits enfants vous allez voir
ça doit être bientôt la fin de
l'émission tu as un micro Julien il est
là il se Batt tous pour avoir le
[Musique]
micro le petit chanteur pleurait plus
chant tout
dégoûé sa petite n par pvre petit ça va
quoi
vie
dans les
journaux il tous ces gens là pour
chanteur
chanteur à la télé c'est sû pour cacher
sa
blessure sur sa figure a de
[Musique]
peinture si tues chanteurs que tu pleur
mon quel cœur bravo le décorateur bravo
il est bien le décorateur détourneur PDG
promoteur ou le
[Musique]
vieuxouleur tu es tout seul dans ton lit
tout
seul est parti le monde s'en fout tu m'a
compris pas moyen ça c'est sû pour
cacher ta blessure chz devant du
vict de
peinture les c'est parti pleurs douleur
hystri Wagner c'est bien
[Musique]
Wagner es pas vraiment
chanteur pas en couleur ton cœur ton
cœur
a pas son
d'éleour
[Musique]
chtion
bien qui joue la
[Musique]
guitare
allez
[Musique]
Victor Victor le
producteur c'est
bien tu as le rythme dans la peau on le
sent tu as le rythme dans la peau tu une
boule de r toi ça se sent ça se sent ce
truc
là
[Musique]
fore